robert spencer you put out a phenomenal
amount of information every every week
and your daily reports are an
outstanding resource informing the world
of the assault on freedom by jihadis
where do you get your daily information
you must have a monster staff
actually no
i'm the only full-time employee of g hot
watch at all and otherwise we have some
very excellent writers
on staff who contribute on a more or
less daily basis uh but
they uh
it's not a full-time thing for them
christine douglas williams who
fitzgerald andrew harrod uh
wonderful india expert ashlyn davis and
a few others here and there who come in
now and again
but mainly it's just me looking around
for news sources that are
news stories i should say that are
relevant to the jihad
these things do end up on the wire
services for the most part but then
they're not picked up by the uh
establishment media sources so you have
to go to godwatch.org to get the full
story
you